[Laughter]
when should you start the story of this
painting here in 1910 or here in 1844
may be here in Cezanne studio at the
close of the 19th century or may be the
only place you can really find the
genesis of this canvas is in Jackson
Pollock's mine the day he began to drip
I'm drawn to ask these questions because
this painting one number 13 1950 is the
only abstract work of art that has ever
floored me in person as soon as my eyes
caught it it made me feel something I
don't know that I could describe the
feeling but I didn't have to go
searching for it either a problem I
often have with non figurative paintings
where I'm standing in front of a canvas
trying to figure out the reaction I'm
having to it feeling guilty because
nothing's coming I don't think the power
of this Pollock depends on its place in
the history of art its style its use of
color its hyperactivity are intrinsic
qualities but I do think the history of
art as a lot to say through Pollock
strip paintings which he'd been making
by this point for about four years in
many ways they're the culmination of
something that has a foggy beginning
about a century or two before with the
gradual end of church and noble
patronage of the Arts and the dawn of
painters painting what was important to
them there's no fixed point where you
could mark the beginning of modern art
some find it in this painting by Monet
from 1863 with its flattened image and
scandal a subject that flow'd the values
of the Paris salon and I think it's as
good a moment as any that year fully 2/3
of submissions to the salon were
rejected and after a public outcry
Emperor Napoleon the third authorized a
second salon to feature them called
appropriately the exhibition of reach
it was a massively popular event and
though these paintings were criticized
as much as they were praised it marked a
moment of legitimacy for art that stood
outside the Academy's hierarchy of
quality once the cat was out of the bag
things started moving very quickly less
than ten years later Claude Monet and
his compatriots launched into
Impressionism concerning themselves not
with the objects they see in the world
but how the light plays off them
Impressionism in turn starts a chain
reaction of well reaction the
post-impressionists begin to dispense
with the effects of light and the
reality of color and paint according to
subjective experience an emotional
vision then the Fobus take the
arbitrariness of color to kaleidoscopic
extremes in the first decade of the 20th
century I mean just look at the
transformation that's happened to
painting in just 40 short years art has
unraveled its centuries long aim of
reproducing the physical world in
perspective color and form is rapidly
being abandoned Vasily Kandinsky
influenced by the Impressionists by the
fauvist by music and by the geometric
spirituality of theosophy starts pulling
away from representation entirely in a
groundbreaking book he writes the more
abstract is form the more clear and
direct its appeal and in 1910 he paints
this in which no objects from our world
can be recognized at all it's the first
fully abstract painting except it turns
out that Hilma op Clint was actually
painting abstracts at least three years
prior to this but no one knew that until
many years later meanwhile Pablo Picasso
and Georges Braque were shaking up
painting in their own way by formalizing
seasons experiments with multiple
perspectives into cubism the Cubist's
used geometry to show reality from many
angles simultaneously Kandinsky takes
inspiration from this but is more
interested in abstracting geometry from
its representational source the sparks
that fly from these investigations
create several other movements futurism
in Italy too style in the Netherlands
suprematism then constructivism in
Russia Dada
in Switzerland and eventually surrealism
in the 1920s and 1930s
a key aspect of the surrealist manifesto
is the focus on automatic creation
writing or speaking without
or thought as a way to access the
unconscious mind painters like Andre
Masson applied this to the visual arts
letting ink run free across paper
creating fluid dreamlike drawings
prefiguring the work of Jackson Pollock
as world war two ravaged Durham several
of the Surrealists and other European
artists escaped to New York City and
began to mix with a new school of
American painters the Americans
synthesized and reacted to all the
various European styles the Abstract
Expressionists as they were called made
work that was deeply personal formally
inventive and confrontational exiled
surrealist Wolfgang Pailin but at best
paintings no longer represent today it
has become the role of the painting to
look at the spectator and ask him what
do you represent Pollock strip paintings
push abstraction to its furthest limit
even in Kandinsky Lyons still bound
recognizable shapes in Pollock there are
no shapes no suggestions to grab on to
the line itself dancing across the
canvas is set free containing nothing
separating nothing there is no inside no
outside nowhere for your eyes to rest
all that remains is energy wild
emotional energy that peers into you not
the other way around I think that's why
I reacted so strongly to this painting
in person
I could feel it looking at me you know
like I said before these drip paintings
have intrinsic value but I also think
they speak to something deep in human
nature that we are obsessive in the same
way that we won't stop until we're
flying among the stars it took less than
a hundred years for this to become this
a fast changing world
contributed hugely of course but beyond
that I do believe there's a drive in us
to take things as far as they can go and
the century of modern art is an
exhilarating example of that it's just
inspiring how irrepressible human
creativity can be
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching this episode was brought to you
by Squarespace if you don't know you can
use Squarespace to make sharp beautiful
websites for anything you might need a
personal site a wedding website a site
for your business or portfolio their
design team has crafted these really
professional looking templates that work
on computer browsers and on mobile
switching perfectly between the two you
can integrate your own photos and videos
with just a few clicks and you can even
link your social account so that you can
auto post to Twitter and Facebook all
from within Squarespace head over to
Squarespace comm for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch don't forget
to go to Squarespace comm / nerdwriter
for 10% off your first purchase thanks
guys I'll see you next time